wenn der ball im tor ist dann
explodierte es einfach lasogga hätten
wir sogar klar kann ich mir vorstellen
dass manche sagen war die kommen da
schon wieder mit 20 leuten oder so wir
sind einfach so wie wir sind hier auch
manchmal einfach verrückt sind und sich
einfach nicht vorstellen
[Applaus]
hat noch lange nicht genug
das zeigt mir schon dass wir voran sind
hier sind wir jetzt auch dann schon am
stadion
[Applaus]
wir sind bei der familie gibt immer
lauter
[Musik]
bevor meine mutter meine beraterin
geworden ist hat sich auch noch andere
berater klappt schon dass ihr mich ernst
die sonst wäre der pianist vertrag
also ich bin nichts verwerfliches daran
das ist ein foto mit meiner mutter bin
nicht so der draufgänger ich habe an
meinen ganzen mut zusammen gefasst wie
angesprochen als war er ein bisschen 23
uhr mit den kumpels auch alles aber erst
das ganze ist einfach jeden tag schön
die beiden irgendwas profen kamen an und
vergibt man einfach mit und dieses jahr
muss man echt sagen da hat man eine
große mission der stadt einfach so zählt
und dem verein mit dem wiederaufstieg
ich glaube da sind wir den leuten auch
eine gewisse art und weise ja etwas
etwas schuldig
[Musik]
mag das einfach rechts noch verkürzen
vielleicht schneiden wir das heißt man
sitzt ja sehen könnte in frage